[00:43:51] Fox News now going to a very negative
Fox News story.
Fox News allowed lunatic Christian Jerry Falwell
Junior to suggest that North Korean dictator
Kim Jong un may have created coronavirus as
a weapon to attack the United States.
We need to listen to doctors.
We need to listen to pandemic specialists.
We need to listen to scientists on coronavirus.
We don't need lunatic Christian preachers
who come from a line of lunatic Christian
preachers in their family, like Jerry Falwell
Jr. to go on television and say these things.
And if they say them, we need them to be held
accountable, which Fox News did not.
So this is a clip of Christian Pastor Jerry
Falwell, Junior associated with Liberty University,
son of the late Jerry Falwell senior, who
once said 9/11 happened because of gay people
and abortions.
His son, Jerry Falwell, Junior goes on Fox
and Friends with Trump regularly watches.
Remember that?
And check out not just what he says, but how
the Fox News clowns don't even push back at
all about it.
[00:44:54][63.4]
[00:44:54] It's just strange to me how so
many are overreacting.
The H1N1 virus in 2009 kills 17000 people.
It was the flu.
Also, I think and there was not the same hype.
It was you just didn't see it on the news
24/7.
And it makes you wonder if there's a political
reason for that.
It's it's you know, impeachment didn't work.
And the Mueller report didn't work.
And.
Article 25 didn't work, and so maybe now this
is their next their next attempt to go, champ.
But but I had.
The owner of a restaurant asked me last night.
He said, do you remember the North Korean
leader promised a Christmas present for for
America back back in December?
Could it be they got together with China?
And this is a president?
I don't know.
But it really is something strange going on.
Jerry, so regarding the fact that you're going
to continue to have classes, people are overreacting.
[00:45:56][61.4]
[00:45:58] There's too much news coverage.
This is politicized.
Corona virus is just like impeachment.
And isn't it possible this was a weaponized
virus created by Kim Jong un and China to
attack the United States?
Fascinating, Jerry.
And and you guys are continuing to hold classes.
That's the reaction from the Fox News people.
Now, let's go through it at two layers at
its face.
This is absurd, first and foremost.
But think about it a little more deeply.
Other countries so far, there's still time.
But so far, other countries have been hit
way harder than the United States, Italy,
Iran, China, Spain.
So why would Kim Jong un punish the United
States by creating a virus that disproportionately
kills people in Europe and Asia, at least
for now?
Every aspect of this appearance is weaponised
ignorance, and it's irresponsible.
It's infowars level stuff that is being allowed
on Fox News.
I told you last week, attorneys general have
been sending out notices to people selling
fake corona viruses like drinking silver.
They should be sending out the same notices
of cease and desist to Fox News for allowing
known disinformation to spread, which will
cause panic and misunderstanding and potentially
cause even more cases of Corona virus and
deaths.
Now, one other thought to consider.
[00:47:18][80.3]
[00:47:20] Jerry Falwell is simultaneously
saying this is all an overreaction and it
might be a North Korean bio weapon.
Think about that for a second.
If this really was a North Korean bio weapon,
aren't we under reacting?
That would be insane.
And effectively an act of war if it is the
case that this is a North Korean bio weapon.
We're not overreacting.
We're drastically under reacting.
But Fox News just says, oh, yeah.
Right.
And and you're continuing to hold classes,
Jerry at Liberty University.
Fascinating.
They've all failed us.
The people that are like the Donald Trump
have failed us as he now is completely in
over his head, lying uncontrollably.
Diarrhea of the mouth.
Can't tell it.
[00:48:04][43.8]
[00:48:04] Can't tell the truth is like Pinocchio
with Donald Trump, except the more he lies,
instead of his nose getting bigger, his face
becomes more orange.
And meanwhile, Fox News is allowing this stuff
and continuing to have people on saying this
is a great time to fly.
The planes will be empty.
This is a great time to go to nice restaurants.
The restaurants will be empty.
These people will be our undoing.
And we are working against not only the virus,
but we are working against the disinformation
viral spread that is happening simultaneously.
[00:48:33][28.8]
[277.6]